the camera sure I'm here oh wait John
can you monitor the comments on your
phone always mostly YouTube what's going
on people also hi you guys know Brianne
you guys know Stacie do they I think
they do on this channel enough this is
the first time they're on so I thought
we'd do a livestream yeah hey guys this
is gonna be a live Q&A you guys could
ask whatever questions you want and
we're gonna answer this reminds me of
friends hey Christopher whoa this this
Facebook livestream all right guys all
right we got like 70 people watching so
far that's pretty good we wouldn't be
nervous like we wanted to little one I
feel like we take away
I'd be worried if we won I feel like
because I would be so scared of winning
that we would actually win yeah Chucky's
outfit right here
although Bronte's wants to know who we
you would cast as Liu Kang if you could
make it mortal kombat very own weak ass
is Luke King yeah yeah he's like the
awesome you think like he's the Jackie
Chan the Donnie Yen of the group but he
couldn't do like a Hadouken but it's a
fireball alright Johnny yeah whoa dude I
think chairman not sirs this guy's is
the first one who ever donated any money
super chair is the coolest thing ever
this is crazy how do we see it John do
you have the comments on your phone so
we can make sure we're shouting out the
right people this is brand new for us we
like to talk about what we're figuring
out on the spot that movie guy one day
dude you're the movie guy to us now I
can you know I'm looking forward to the
Uncharted dude Jose donello dude your
name sounds like dildo I like that so on
whoa whoa I'm breaking everything guys
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna fix the
thing right here so I can view the
comments on the computer special thanks
on YouTube songs beast bro gaming sent
us a few pounds wow dude you guys are
really helping us out during the ad
pocalypse people I appreciate that
good morning to Germany
Louise wants us to show the most action
Stacey's got a nice feeling thanks
Michael Briggs New Zealand Dollars guys
whoa this is the first time ever let's
put this on me okay now we can see the
comments I feel like we're in the future
I'm gonna exit this is this Facebook one
is like alright guys we're gonna get
everything in order right now so we can
just see the comments guys I got to tell
you we we totally are Nexus crazy sorry
we're getting it all in order right now
I should have done this before
there's the comments okay we got it all
in order so you can all read an official
smooth livestream with you guys cuz
maybe the first time we're doing this
might be the first oh yeah this is the
first the second time we're doing this
is kind of hard you better kick toptenz
ass that movie guy I could tell you all
John broke is a [ __ ] John wrote goes a
[ __ ] so throw Ragnarok was pretty dope
yes he does Oh somebody on Facebook just
asked Thor Ragnarok or Justice League
I can with teetee not just his like this
is the biggest foam he's done so far but
if you look at his other work like ego
wears a shark it's one of my favorite
like well we do the shadows yeah yeah
so even wear like that man jumper
stickers on the Facebook with sub Jimmy
stay games of Saiyans how do we see the
people who hate Tim I mentor songs $1
dad you know it's you I'm so sexy my
friend time inator songs this is a scary
thing about going live on YouTube is so
many comments on dope coax and anal
what's up Duke oh hey that's who Stacy
will shout out did you hear about
Jackman wanting to come back as
Wolverine for Avengers yeah yeah yeah
who wouldn't want to do that
good good point guys you got to ask
questions to Stacy and Brienne there
kiddo right now we can go live any time
they're here right now with us one right
here right now yeah one person here just
commented Anil we I think John is the
delay wants to watch taragan Jeff
Peterson has a great choice in movies
that's for sure a question for them anal
or oral guys be respectful for once in
your life
guys I wish a million planes yes Bradley
Hanson those are shining pants we will
be doing a livestream on leg very soon
our live streams are gonna be moving
over to patreon exclusively but since
they see a Breanna here this is like
playing for television screens at once
leave our children videos that they'll
watch on multiple tablets guys who are
the ones who who do put some money down
here in this super check is we never had
anyone even do that for we got the man
Tyson we got beast bro gaming everyone
who actually gave some money you guys
got a you guys got an ass-kisser
questioner we got an answer that [ __ ]
Michael Briggs up in New Zealand to do
this that's why it's plugged into
[Music]
Jonathan Peck we did see your message
Thank You Stacey what is your lip color
uh it is crimson peak just like the
movie that I loved it was like a horror
Romeo last collab we you set yourself up
for so many sex questions now you know
it's fine though cuz that happens every
time we do videos together well we're
not live it's just in the comment boxes
okay comment box Breanna I don't get
sexual I've been on my box
I did find that a box shows that you
can't see my name says he's gay for Greg
you know what I feel like a lot more gay
guys like me than any straight woman I
feel like we should have been gay for
Greg t-shirt I think I'd be a great do
the this Kurosaki do but you got to go
cheap on the friends reference people
did not tour songs
thanks man time inator his name is Tyson
Trini Guddu says John you [ __ ] I love
you oh cool well I want to ask if you're
working on putting more music out a mile
am I'm working on putting more music
eventually I gotta learn how to write a
song first let me tell you usually in
choirs that you can do that the point my
is that I am working on it currently
yeah Stacie Chris hi Chris
I'm sure there's a way to screenshot
these questions small back to your whole
Netflix picks what are some hidden gems
on Netflix that are worth checking out
house down the snow town murders I just
watched glow it was amazing you know it
is this know top earners is great she
doesn't like it because it's dark and
twisted but I like I say iron fist third
season the bloodline fifty shades darker
those are the best shoes from people I
hear Ozark is like everybody says they
haven't been that compelled since
Breaking Bad really everybody
yeah like the only things I hear and
that sentence together Ozark and
Breaking Bad there is one movie I want
everyone to watch it's called my father
the hero
yes in garrard ooh
is a 15 year old girl but she wants to
impress a boy she likes at this resort
she was like a cabin boy or he's what
there's his parents or something sushi
Brendan's at her dad I sort of like
older lover and that she's 19 you mister
ridiculous it's so weird
and I don't know why I watched it but I
watched it was a cult my father the hero
and I do we got a do we are recruiting
Rachel join us Greg I saw you on tinder
and I super light to you lines though
someone super like me on tinder I
deleted my tinder app many months ago
why and I'm a good boyfriend like that
yeah I don't keep my apps I took my [ __ ]
you to the ex her pants look like the
floor and the shining Nate the great
random called it that's exactly what it
is this guy has to go back to work
[Music]
this guy really wants to know if we
smoke weed he keeps asking he has to go
back to work I haven't in years no
that's not true I spoke with you a
little bit she spoke to me once a tiny
bit did absolutely zero to her I went
out with her friends and I was paranoid
the entire the banana mafia only get
like private messages first I would like
to say except involved what is beautiful
yeah
are you asking me are you asking him him
he wants to take you on a beautiful
beautiful this is more money than videos
I get a hundred thousand I'm not gonna
bring my girlfriend out to this channel
No I'm Stacie that's also Stacie and
that's John Greg are you still planning
to kill Tyrone do you guys know Tyrone
Magnus I will kill Tyrone
I will you guys haven't seen my
celebrity crushes both young and silver
foxes Ryan Gosling Harrison Ford
what are you oh they're asking what
songs but your old celeb Rika and then
well was yours well the young one is
definitely Chris Evans my young ones
Jake Gyllenhaal I'm just saying you know
she's not in her 20s good my own one is
Joe Pesci ha ha ha my young one is the
kid in wonder my legally allowed to joke
like Aaron Howard says Tyrone has more
subscribers of you just FYI oh yeah I
didn't know that are usually forgotten
somewhere in the back of my mind I think
he has a catchphrase that might indicate
do you guys follow Conor McGregor Floyd
Mayweather stuff you guys like to like
like watch grown men beat each other yes
UFC dude you're already pledging so much
on patreon do you three buckets and
that's probably time to you Jeff Jeff
Harris get Peterson
I'll take dude you get my bro can't
actually fight guys why does everybody
type an age greg's pube head ass boy
they can't say the n-word here
what do you mean Richie sink who would
win the rumor emoji movie to you I think
the room has proven itself timeless and
lovable and always de mogi movie
probably won't tear Timman eats her
songs why we've been saying a different
name this whole time because he said
time inator I told you oh he actually
said that
I'm sorry Tyson John looks like a coyote
Orlando Bloom we to get this [ __ ]
organized right now Thank You anyone
else feel like that it's like an ADHD
room in here
they do be beast bro game game gaming
Bruce we're streaming on YouTube as well
you guys dude okay yeah
beast bro gaming you should come to my
you could totally do all this Oh sup
Rachel are you doing Rachel from the old
improv days hey Greg let's be on it hey
Rachel Jackson miss you doll let's be
honest we all love Tyra but no can match
the quality of your beautiful body that
is true dude Tyrone is what you call
very fat those ABS is really a bunch of
fat six specific spots
oh look a real question I want to see
pickle Rick what y'all are your most
hype for this fall season movie you have
children that stuff that stuff I guess
the new I guess you know the last Jedi
Oh
it's California is there really a
difference between fall and winter yes
and one has no leaves are you guys gonna
have an orgy after the now that was
before yeah I'm glad you asked what's
your question rate because I only give
them to people that ask we have some
sexy photos on your Instagram on Miss
movies on Instagram
those are the only photos I like of hers
everything else family children I don't
care about that right but if she's like
recreating a photo from like a classic
80s movie yeah then I'll like that and
comment that's Tahrir too easily I loved
you that's easy it's a better movie I'm
saying I almost love it more than t2
judgment a it isn't fun it's yeah I
don't know I'm gonna say true light so
you take to you too I'll teach realize
we'll be opposing to do favorite what's
this ring James my favorite flavor of
ice cream is chocolate with what's your
favorite horror movie signs of the Lambs
yes screams my favorite horror movie Jon
yours my favorite horror movie that's
really Texas Chainsaw Massacre is a
favorite the thing is a favorite trick
or treat you want to fix your hair what
do you read different mirrors or ways to
fix that everyone I what's your favorite
action movie
Christopher Victoria wants to know
favorite action movie dude banana mafia
is really trying to get you ten more
bucks at the beach do you shoot Jim
Morrison can Rachel wants to react to
some Japanese stuff do you think we can
make that happen
sure when she's out here she's out here
no dude okay but Nana mafia I really
feel like Stacey would actually go on
this date with you let me like kiss her
if there's a trash can here is this
Greg's the prettiest one out of all of
us ah I'm sorry I should be listen
very cream we're all in this can't I'm
in a relationship
favorite movie of the summer Wonder
Woman cars three cuz I felt like she
spoke to me on a personal level and I
remember when the girl got cast the
actress got cast as her I saw it like
I'm some you know Anoosh or whatever and
I was like like that was my role like I
wasn't an actress you know I'm not gonna
get that role but I felt like she stole
from being what was rightfully mine
Matt Damon says what's the worst date
you've ever been on bran has been on so
many dates with so many different men
it's really good it's insane chief
probably has horror stories for you on
the worst day she's ever been I can't
think of bloomers what is your favorite
part in the song good answer safe answer
you know what do you mean like well I
was at a sorority in college and most of
the guys that I met were like in
fraternities which is fine for you know
being friends but as far as dating them
they weren't the best people today
really ya think I'm a Gemini feel like
they've you know
not the chest
Daniel Barker
oh hi Greg much love from Scotland
hopefully join patreon to help support
your awesome content
Daniel Barker thank you so much I love
that Scotland you ever hang out with
Jeremy Jones loves to break into a
school fish accent love to Philippines
yeah I love Filipinos jollibee guys guys
great question Rico right question here
great question arey what yes lethal
weapon or die hard
I don't want your shocks from the
audience you have never seen what what
you never seen the Lido Greg I know you
can see me baby remember in high school
we did it for a couple weeks and date
anybody in high school you are a liar
oh my god I can't take my shirt off
right over here is incredible okay well
you know this movie is coming apart all
right guys we're gonna wrap this up in a
couple minutes cuz they have plans other
than this craziness that we're getting
right
we just said this to go live I'll take
one of my shirts off
I like the shirt how many do you have on
just this one in the undershirt do you
guys like rock for me Breaking Bad or
walking to Breaking Bad no way over
Walking Dead for sure
iron fist Michael Myers are Leatherface
Michael Myers thanks Stacey we finally
agree on something
Oh Leatherface I'm from Texas I have to
say that huh you know I might go with on
their face actually I feel like like
whether face is kind of more compelling
than Michael don't you don't need to
touch your friends noses sometimes
sometimes I pick them I do that Greg
countries too that's all touch there we
go
these are your wives dream beautiful
[Music]
Gregory you see they're man-made Jesus
Adonis you make my loins burn and burst
with sensual lust and passion that's
crazy
Marvel's blade is coming to Netflix your
wines are burning and bursting it means
you have chlamydia I actually don't know
if that's the same fix as a drag but I
am not surprised in the least
bran has never been high it's one of my
goals and let okay here's the deal we
compete on the showdown we win if we win
you have to yeah and then we have you
live stream you're talking about like us
competing together no thank you for your
injection versus hit or miss movies six
degrees a reach-around sorry
all right just six degrees you guys have
so many different names we don't six
degrees okay
beasts programming so when did Ryan turn
to Greg that's a long story but I didn't
want to be known as
a pervert any more than people thought
and that hasn't really changed much it's
the same exact image I just like my name
war yeah you'll get an explanation real
much people in the livestream in a
second don't worry stranger things are
Game of Thrones game of things came of
things okay dude you got some banana
mafia will you go on the date with him
maybe send her a dick pic first no yeah
do that
that's how Stacey judges every day in
particular out they did I don't
understand why some guys just said dick
dicks and don't do you guys get worst
movie of the year so far
Dark Tower no way we saw something way
worse than that there was a horrible
know what was the movie Transformers
five is pretty horrible I feel like
there was something that would be a
better answer like I feel like
transformers movies are always kind of
like a dummy answer like CD they're like
what about you guys was not good but you
guys know how big of a fan I am of 1999
is the movie we know so that being said
I went to this knowing that I wouldn't
like it and it couldn't compare to my
great love of Brendan Fraser so but I
went anyway and there were elements to
it where I was like this is interesting
but I wasn't interested in it like it
should be interesting but I wasn't
this is the only dick pic you'll ever
need yes yeah Van Dyke is pretty alright
we're gonna wrap myself in a minute guys
like a minute or two you guys gonna get
your the last questions in we're gonna
answer three more questions I wanted to
start answering I don't dream that your
cheese and I love your name I want it no
no I want to start a dick pic company
and somebody took my idea we're like you
know instead of just sending like you
know just like a dick like it's a fish
or something you know like make a
tableau and then dress your dick in like
costume and that penis kinda yeah so
like make a little boiler room set and
then like give your dick like a little
hat a sweater and like a spiky glove and
then like even if they don't want to get
a dick it's like oh cool I like Freddie
though so like it would like at least
increase the goodwill you know you
really do have that uh what's the
problem a smoke you ready for your
listening face [ __ ] face yeah I can't
say that to you to your face a resting
[ __ ] face yeah you have this like no
just watching your face guys look out we
both have upcoming matches and we both
have great entrances we could say that
much right you like our entrances yeah
we had good entrances are people a lot -
no it's awesome the entrances that's
true most satisfying death scene and TV
show um Viserys on Game of Thrones the
golden crown
[Music]
they'll talk about any season seven
stuff yeah Jon Secada wait what was the
question first season yeah it's like
Episode four I like it when when Robb
Stark's pregnant wife got stabbed
so that's great moment for women no just
I didn't like the rest just in the
pregnant wife got staff investment I
don't like babies in the belly wait was
this a game of Thrones question only
television how's about that ATM death in
Breaking Bad Ren's friends are Seinfeld
friends know Seinfeld know French
space-saving curb
Daniel Barker master theater company
John do you mean like the real rejects
as a company or just for me to spend
time with you you can't see my name I'm
not gonna have sex with you and aqus on
how do I think this matter how bad I
want to I can't Daenerys will there will
be like a battle on the second to last
episode and then the episode after that
will be people setting up for seasoning
alright guys here's the here's the final
question final question final that's not
a where to go I just saw it I wanna see
James a gonna he's been a part of this
channel for so long we gotta answer his
question who's your favorite late-night
talk show host of all time my answer is
easy I know it easily thought my head
yeah Chelsea Handler easily when Tom
Green had his talk show that was the
best but Tom Green show Mike's Conan
O'Brien he is my hero my favorite talk
show host of all time is Craig Ferguson
know it's a good choice on twice and
that was a tremendously fun experience
I did see Jay Leno twice
so I don't know I was on jaywalking guys
you weren't cheating is it on the
Internet can I see it I'll send you a
link please do oh my god you answer
questions who's your favorite
I said choice see you she's your
favorite yeah Stacy's over this all
right well we're gonna wrap it up thank
you all who like and cheers it's a super
chat we weren't expecting anyone in the
super chat and that's a genuine thought
we actually even said before laughter
like yeah no one ever gives money in the
super chat so for you guys who did do
that thank you so much thank you thank
you all for being here Stacy and Brienne
they will split five hi everyone just a
tip